I've been saying this for a while but
Mashable now agrees with me Facebook is
actually ruining your life that's right
they came up with 10 reasons to show why
Facebook is ruining your life and we've
got all 10 first up no one sends you
birthday cards anymore
this is totally true when was the last
time I get a birthday card for my mom
you know what I mean I used to get them
from my grandma's they're not here
anymore they're not sending them from
the afterlife but do you get birthday
cards anymore yeah I mean I'm old school
if you haven't met my family like we got
a stack of cards like this if you marry
into our family they're like why are you
sending us car I mean I mailed a card
literally on the way to here this
morning yeah it feels good to mail
doesn't it feel like you're actually
doing something and yeah stamp on and
your return address and you actually
write a personal note um I mean I guess
it's diminishing you know the amount of
cards that are being sent but I still
think that a card goes a long way so I
don't for in my personal life I still I
still receive cards and I'll give you my
address do you think that the two
seconds that it takes for someone to
write on someone's wall is an acceptable
form of saying happy birthday I mean I
feel like that's what a lot of people
who do when their acquaintances you know
if someone's a closer friend they'll
give you a call or they'll take you off
your birthday or hang out you know in
person maybe snapchat you a nudie
snapchat I know these yeah that that's a
thing that could happen very possible
number two
you hear important news after everyone
else this is you know when somebody has
a baby or somebody got married and you
think that they're gonna tell you via
text or something or a call and it
doesn't happen we've all had this happen
right yeah I wouldn't even want to hear
if someone had a baby via text I want
that personal call from that woman who
just pushed that baby out so you want to
send out a birthday cards and you want
actual phone crap no yeah I do agree
it's kind of weird when you're like oh
they're married or you know and that's
fine I'd rather have it is kind of the
way things are at these days but it's
the thing that annoys me is when people
post really awful news you know and like
oh my gosh you know my dad is on this
last and then do you like write then you
like yeah like that he's dying
picture in the hospital bed like clearly
some people posting yeah awful pictures
like good news is one thing bad news I'm
not a fan of hearing hearing it or
looking at it on things on the Facebook
number three you have major lifestyle
and V so this one I think is
particularly interesting actually
because everyone seems cooler online and
they've done Studies on this where
because even because of Instagram your
food looks better than regular food your
teaches yeah the beach is the brighter
and the sunsets look better and all that
do you get that feeling of like jealousy
when you see people doing all this know
what they're doing I do the same thing
everyone wants to look like their life
is awesome online I mean at least that's
what I do and a lot of my friends do
it's like I'm not gonna post the
depressing [ __ ] on my Facebook I'm gonna
be like it today was great here's my
food yeah you know no foodie knows that
chat food okay I don't really alright
all films books and TV shows are ruined
for you this one to me this one's more
about Twitter because if you are trying
to not watch something live you have to
stay off Twitter it's as simple as that
spoilers we've all had things spoiled
for us right bachelor and the
Bachelorette I can't stand cuz like I
can't ever watch them like as they're
happening because I don't like
commercial assault reportage that trash
I do that's like my one guilty pleasure
I'll watch that show but yeah it's like
if I haven't watched the episode I
cannot even go on Facebook so I'll see
all my girlfriend so be like oh my god
he picked this girl or he didn't pick
this girl I'm like damn it
yeah it's Facebook ruining television no
yes what are you watching um I mean I'm
watching the deep Rubin show they're my
computer so that's pretty much only two
all right there you go what's next
number five it's ruined your diet so
yeah this is just people posting the
food thing which we already got to so
let's keep rolling number six you
realize how boring some of your old
friends are I think this one is totally
at least applicable to my life because I
see people that somehow I ended up
friends with you know from high school
or junior high or whatever and then they
just have boring regular lives and god
bless them but I don't really care about
their boring lives you're a cat woman
right so I wasn't really a
sighting picture I post pictures of my
cat I thought that was thrilling but
yeah I do find the old people that
you're now friends with you find their
lives very boring you're a hip chick I
don't really agree with you yes on this
one especially like there's those other
certain friends who post every two
minutes like up the B is getting ready
for the store
he's getting ready to go outside and
it's like or they lost their kids I get
it kids you put clothes on them great
all right what's that number seven you
realize how boring you are and this is
someone that made a video having fun
driving in snow yeah I mean this is just
the the culture of oversharing we're all
guilty of this right right we all just
put [ __ ] out there that nobody really
cares okay what's next you suffer from a
serious case of FOMO so this one's sort
of like the food one because people
always appear to be out and doing better
things so you're saying your life isn't
as cool in real life as it appears oh
yeah
definitely not is your life where yes
pretty balanced pretty balanced I mean I
would say that the highlights are on
Facebook post the highlights it's like a
movie trailer you post all the cool
stuff and then it's like sometimes movie
doesn't live up to and then you get
serious serious FOMO Oh Bobo if you
don't know what FOMO is the kids taught
me this one it's fear of missing out
what's their number died Facebook's
targeted ads have ruined your confidence
and yeah this is because they're a lot
of their targeted ads or about gyms and
they keep it's a lot of like people with
abs and great bodies is that is that
ruining your well done Joe what happens
to me is I spend more because like I was
researching to do a trip to Cabo and all
of a sudden all these things are like
you know Expedia has a deal to Cabo or
to try this Resort yeah you know so
advertising actually works I think
because then I'll click on the link yeah
I get sucked into that vortex guilty
yeah thought I get cat litter ads a lot
of cats all right and finally number 10
the average American this is what the
according to Mashable the average
American Facebook user spends 40 minutes
a day on the site which is a little over
10 collective day
per year you spend on Facebook think
about that if you're spending 40 minutes
a day that's 10 days of your life per
year that's a lot of time on the
Facebook Facebook yeah how do you
control the amount of time you use I
just really try to focus on everybody's
positive affirmations that they post so
at least the ten days are well spent
yeah how you control it I probably spend
way more than that on Facebook to be
honest but I mean like doing social
media work and being online and so I
have to be online a lot right we're
online people we have I live in the
internet a little bit so we're living in
the internet right now and how much time
do you spend on Facebook I hope you're
spending more time on YouTube comment in
the section right down below and don't
forget to subscribe and like because
that's the Facebook thing apparently